all right the real estate industry is
booming during this time if you didn't
know so we caught up with the palacios
realty team to get an update
let's just get into it is the housing
market still at
breakneck speed is what you call it how
fast
things are moving it's really
historically unprecedented
uh our inventory levels are so thin
right now
uh that it's just really reflecting how
fast
homes are moving off of the market and
so
that's my breaking neck yes so fast
you're going to get whiplash that's
right
so and and so to answer the question is
it still at that
you know intense speed well we're not
seeing the intensity as it was like 30
days ago
we're definitely seeing a strong
competition we're still seeing
uh that our inventory levels haven't
changed uh
we just we're also seeing the buyers pay
cash over appraised values but
we're just not seeing as many or as
intense as it was about three day
30 days ago or a few weeks ago a couple
of reasons why that's kind of cooled off
in that sense is because we have seen
rates kind of tick up so it's taken a
portion of the buyer pool out of the
equation
we've also seen some buyers say you know
what i'm just going to wait for summer
time
i'm going to wait for more inventory
that's a smart move is it still a good
time to refinance it's a popular
question
goodness absolutely of course it is it's
actually always a good time to refinance
if you have an adjustment on your terms
uh we are seeing historically low rates
period and i mean regardless of what we
hear drama-wise as far as rates taking
up
it's still historically low and if you
purchase fha or conventional over the
last few years or even more
well you can benefit from a straight up
rate reduction which translates into a
lower monthly payment
also consider eliminating pmi we've seen
home
prices appreciate aggressively over the
last 20
last couple of years so that 80 20 ratio
that the banks are looking for
uh will will help eliminate that pmi now
besides those two
uh you can also uh benefit from maybe a
two month
uh weight you can refinance and not pay
your mortgage for two months
others they want to be able to tap into
the equity uh maybe
do some home remodels or maybe pay off
some debts
one way or another every single one of
those decisions
is a personal decision for each family
it's unique it's why i love this
business because uh every situation
requires a different set of calculations
so if you need some expert opinions
we're absolutely here to help you can
call us for a free list of references we
take a look at the resale options our
severe lack of inventory
uh you know purchasing a new home
actually has multiple upsides for you
right now
uh the obvious one being that you picked
a lot the home style
even all of the upgrades and the best
part is there's no history that you're
inheriting
with the new home right there's two big
benefits that
really really come to come to play here
uh especially in this current
housing market uh when you're moving on
a new home you're buying it based on the
for
the developers build dates so you know
actually when you're moving in
and that translates into like if you
have to sell a house
when you can sell the house and how to
transfer that money over and the second
one is peace of mind
you know you don't have to compete so
aggressively in the resale market
i will take gladly take a new home
alright give palacios realty a call at
702-333-6666 for more information
and they have a special offer for you
mention channel 8 for a free
one year home warranty with home
purchase
yeah make that mention all right